[Music]
[Applause]
luna
the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's
the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to my show i'm
really excited to jump straight into
this one because
this is gonna be um a fun topic put it
this way i've been trying to get this
guy on for quite a few
maybe like over a year now i think it's
been so i'm very excited but before we
jump in
um it is powered by icon plus capital so
quick news announcement for you so
the new d5 platform running on icon is
now live
um on balance you can stick icx's
collateral to borrow usd interest free
and also
they provide around seven percent um
daily interest on yield farming rewards
now this is also um sponsored by block
five so quick shout out to them you can
get up to eight point six percent
interest on your usdc
um so i'll leave a link for you
somewhere and everywhere now before
i bring on my guest um if you are
watching on youtube please don't forget
to hit subscribe
hit the like button so you never miss
any of these brilliant guests
so today joining me like i said is
someone i have been trying to get on for
um quite some time who's a bitcoin
advocate investor
financial consultant and the founder and
ceo of the financial consulting firm
atlantic financial it is bruce benton
bruce how are you great how are you
great to see you
yeah it's really good to see you as i
was saying i think i've been trying to
chat to you have a good podcast have a
good chat for
maybe over a year now yeah that doesn't
surprise me i
i used to do these once in a while and i
haven't done a lot for
for quite some time i've done some
clubhouses but i haven't appeared on any
i don't know this may be one of the
first in a while maybe i've done a few
in the last year if that
so i don't do too many of them oh well i
feel honored but you mentioned clubhouse
which is pretty interesting
what are your thoughts on that right now
because i think i heard i think i read
some news the other day that the
downloads of that is actually
going down yeah they kind of have to
because they had so many
you know soon everybody will have it but
i think it's great i wish i would have
sent a check to them and tried to invest
my i had an idea by the time i heard
about it everybody
i mean i was pretty early but but but
the other
i was using number about 4 800 but i
think like 4 000 of the other ones were
all vcs so it wasn't like it was a
secret you know so it would have been
easy for them to
to raise money um but i thought about
just sending you know i've heard of
people investors sending a check
and just saying hey let me in on your
next round like no terms no
nothing i i thought about taking a risk
and doing that it might have been early
enough
i don't know if they would have but i
sure wish i would have invested i i knew
for sure this one was going to be a big
hit and it has been it's a great
it's a great format so that's cool you
don't think it's sort of like hit its
peak and it's potentially
coming down from there uh probably not
its peak i think it
it hit its initial like um
adoption curve kind of you know it's it
that that you can only be hot and new
once you know but it still has a ways to
go i don't even know if they have
android yet but once they do that they
should have
uh quite a bit um you know quite quite a
bit more users and
and i think there will be more people
that have large followings that have
large rooms and some podcasts that might
migrate there and other things so
it's still early i i would imagine it's
probably going to be a pretty cool
looking platform in a few years
but there may be others the other thing
is it's easy for somebody else to come
and replace it
yeah yeah that's the thing with social
media these days it's just a matter of
everybody just copying what everybody's
doing i mean
even going back a few years snapchat did
the stories
instagram you know twitter with the
spaces it's just one thing after the
other but um
i want to go back a little bit learn a
bit more about you and how you initially
got into the space before we talk about
everything
um that i've been dying to speak to
about sure
yeah i started in the investment
business when i was a little kid
basically my mom was a stock broker
and uh in the and i kind of grew up in
the brokerage firm floor i would come
there every day
every day after school not just some
days but every day i'd come there
and i'd just play on the floor and
listen to the brokers
talking and that this was a different
time you know that the 80s especially
like uh
it was more like the crypto space it was
exciting there was a lot of money it was
you know there's brokers yelling there's
drama people
arguing with each other you know they
even in those days when i was a little
kid they were still like
verbally doing orders you know so people
would be yelling across the floor you
buy
300 shares well you know and i thought
that was really cool
and we had the crazy kind of cool
stories like we have in crypto
my mom came home one day and told me
about
somebody in her office who got arrested
um and the sec came the sec came with
the police and like and the fbi and they
arrested somebody
yeah so it's just crazy uh it was a
crazy industry and so
i was interested in that very young and
by and when i was 14 i got like a real
job there
as an assistant uh back when you were
allowed to do that you were even allowed
to call customers
really yeah yeah i mean you know you
have to be licensed
uh to do most of the things uh to they
just they made it more strict about what
you had to be you used to be able to
kind of call and sort of pre-qualify
people
cold call for a broker um but now you
need to be licensed to do that but
so i started very early and i did that
um you know when i when i was a little
kid all the way through my teens
and then when i got out of the navy i
went and got a full-time job at
dean witter which was as a stockbroker
financial advisor so i did that for for
20 something years or you know about
around 20 years and and i
focused on emerging markets and emerging
technologies
and that went well you know we we were
early on the internet and we did
well with the dot-com boom and uh and
bust we called the bust actually
and then uh so i was familiar with this
kind of thing so so crypto was a natural
uh thing for me i was interested in free
markets uh
economics globalization technology sort
of checked all those boxes for me
so i got into crypto about eight years
ago and
sort of started working full-time there
wasn't really like paid
work or companies you know there was
only i think two or three companies that
had venture funding
and there was probably only half a dozen
jobs that were paid you know there was
like gavin andreessen
and i i became executive director of the
bitcoin foundation so we would pay
uh or that organization used to pay
those kind of salaries um and so i've
been in it ever since and i've been
interested in the things that converge
those two areas that i came from
securities and and crypto and bitcoin
uh and the rest is history i guess
yeah i think it's fascinating because
you've been able to see such a change in
that financial space like you were
saying
back when you were 14 they were making
you know actual calls and
and all these things and i think that
wild west is sort of what we're seeing
now and you can
make those synergies in in some ways but
you've been really vocal when it comes
to d5 i remember you you did that video
and it was like the drawing and the fire
and
that was fun um but i can't i do want to
talk a little bit about d5 and
all the different things that are being
built right now um
so firstly would you regard yourself at
all as a bitcoin maximalist
i like the term jameson lope it was the
first one i heard say it which is
bitcoin monetary maximalist
so i believe that bitcoin is the best
money and store of value
and i think bitcoin is the best doing
for the the thing that it's trying to do
but uh unlike some people who are who
are just sort of
the next sentence they would say is
everything else is junk i don't think
everything else is junk i'm optimistic
particularly about security securities
have value
they just do whether you like it or not
you know it doesn't
being a token doesn't erase the value so
i think it's a very neanderthal
uh idea to say like all tokens are bad
and they always will be other than
bitcoin that's just
uh not nuanced not that smart
neanderthal view
uh but you know it comes it's rooted in
something that's kind of true which is
that almost all of these things are junk
uh so so you you know i take the the
technology i'm excited about the ideas
i'm excited about but they're
you know i'm definitely one of the first
to say that there's a lot of just junky
projects you know projects that don't
make sense
and i don't i don't like the word i
think the word scam is overused more
much more common than scams and some are
scams
much more common that scams are just you
know real naive
uh people or you know naive plans or
just um
naive to the point of being negligent
almost where people just just have such
a bad idea
that it almost has the same function as
a scam
and and they just very naive but overall
i'm kind of uh
you know more open-minded than than most
people who might refer to themselves as
pure bitcoin maximalist
yeah i appreciate that i think nuances
is really important and we're seeing you
know the building of web 3 and
everything that you saw you know since
the beginning of the internet
um i just think it's so um i do think
it's closed-minded
to not be open to what could come next
so i kind of want your opinion in terms
of deep buy what kind of value do you
think it brings and where do you see
where do you see that value um in
comparison to bitcoin so i guess
you would look at bitcoin as that store
of value and
defy and everything that's been built on
ethereum where do you see that playing
out
yeah so d5 is pretty broad uh term
overall and it encompasses a lot
so kind of defining it is sometimes hard
when it first came out it was just sort
of like
you know it sounds like everything else
you know but but
if you get into what it really should
mean which is the two
two words decentralized and finance
that's pretty easy so you want to look
at something that's truly decentralized
and then with that you ask well why do
you need it decentralized some things it
doesn't make sense to
decentralize early in the bitcoin era
people were talking about dows and stuff
just
sort of decentralizing for the sake of
decentralizing it doesn't
always make sense and in some cases like
a company it can actually be
a negative you do sort of want to have
centralization sometimes the best
companies have
that you know elon musk or jack welsh or
whoever's driving it
um and then the other part is is finance
and that's pretty broad also that
includes lending lending's a huge part
of finance
it includes securities which is what i'm
most interested in
so i think that it's very early stage i
think there's it's kind of like
um when when electricity first came out
people were saying wow this is so
exciting and you had
products that didn't make sense like you
had electric shoes and electric hats and
people like oh
i'm making an electric hat company don't
don't you don't get it
you don't you don't understand
electricity is going to the moon
electricity is going to be important
and it's like well yeah but it doesn't
mean that the hat makes sense and that's
kind of the way d5 is and decentral more
broadly distributed ledgers
the idea that you can have a ledger that
is run by peers rather than a trusted
person
or party uh is a big deal and but but
you want to think about where that makes
sense
securities is one area that it does make
sense so i'm very excited about
securities
and defy i've been disappointed that a
lot of the
kind of main groups and people that
you think of as the d5 leaders haven't
been looking at securities and i think
that's due to misconceptions you know
they think like oh we don't need to do
regulated stuff we'll do
this other thing and it doesn't quite
work like that with securities because
securities are driven
in the united states by a definition so
it's like the
the definition's super broad so all the
good stuff like equity
and sharing profits and having real
governance that actually matters
all of these kind of things it's going
to qualify it as a security and you
can't really change that definition
unless you change these 85 year old
rules so
your option now is either comply or try
to make something that
is outside the definition uh which
usually is not going to end up being
something good the definition
long long long ago already sort of
captured everything that
is good so i'd like to see more defy and
securities converge i think that that'll
be powerful and i'm sure that it will
come around
oh i can't hear you i think you've just
muted yourself
while you i'm you um so with all of that
with all of that in mind then i kind of
want to get your thoughts on xrp yeah we
can hear you now i wouldn't i want to
get your thoughts on xrp then because
the case is still going on um there's
been a few
wins um so i just wanted one to
understand where you stand on that and
you know whether you think it's a
security or not
um i know you obviously were very um pro
the d-listing because if it is a
security then it should be de-listed
um and also if it is regarded as a
security would that be good for it
oh we can't hear you we still can't hear
you
let's see if we can
no we still can't hear you having some
tech issues guys
okay well guys we have a lot to talk
about so
just hang on while bruce tries to get
the get the mic going we still
we still plan you but while he does that
i'm gonna let you know
what's coming because um
like i said i have been trying to speak
to bruce for a while and
i think we share some similar opinions
when we talk about what's going on in
the world in general when it comes to
covid when it comes to vaccines
um so i definitely want to delve into
that we still can't hear you bruce
sorry oh there we go we can hear you
yeah
we can hear you yeah yeah yeah about
that i'm just giving away
i've just given away what i want to what
i want to delve into in a bit
but but we'll we'll get that but first i
want to hear your thoughts on xrp
because that case is still going
um and you know you're obviously very
interested in security so if it is
regarded as a security
how will this play out yeah i mean we'll
see what the
nobody can predict what the what the
outcome will be the case isn't really so
much
about whether it's a security or not and
i don't
think that it will rule on that i think
it's because
judges typically from what i understand
don't like to go
beyond uh what they're tasked with it's
hard enough judge
job to be a judge and if they if the
law isn't saying this is a question
where the judge is tasked with deciding
whether this is a security or not
i don't know if they're going to opine
on that uh because that's just
extra work and risk for a judge they
risk getting overturned you know ripple
is obviously going to fight that if they
i mean
if they said it is a security or not so
the the the suit
kind of assumes it's a security and the
sec
does generally have uh authority to say
what a security is
so xrp's argument is and ripple's
argument is well you're wrong
it's not a security and here's why so
it's crucial to their defense
and so it's certainly possible that that
that you know in a perfect world for
them the judge would say yeah you're
absolutely right you're not a security
and he would actually
he or she would actually rule on rule on
that
and uh and then it would be a win a win
for them
of the case and it would clarify this
this uh
status that it's not security i don't
think that will happen even if the case
goes their way
i i think it would be um overly
optimistic for them you know i don't
know if their lawyers are like hoping
that but i
uh you know they're super super
sophisticated and smart on this so
uh you know i'm sure they're realistic
about it their main goal i think is just
to not lose
you know because it's sort of stacked
against you when you have a case of this
nature even though you have very good
lawyers or whatever
um it's kind of stacked against them
from from day one as far as whether it's
a security or not it's certainly
um they certainly make a case for it in
that in
in the in the complaint you know and and
the sec saying something is
security is pretty harsh it's like if
the dea says something's a drug
you know i've used an analogy before if
the dea goes into walgreens and says hey
this
cbd lemonade is not really cbd it's thc
two two things one it's really hard for
that lemonade company to go and fight
the
cdc or i'm sorry the the dea
and and two walgreens would be insane
you you know you mentioned de-listing
walgreens would be insane to
still keep doing that so i i couldn't
believe that people were having
discussions
you know exchanges most exchanges
delisted but i couldn't believe there
was any discussion once you have a
federal regulatory authority
say something is uh is a security
therefore
it's illegal for you to deal in if
you're not a registered securities
broker
i think they'd be crazy not to because
you're basically banking your whole
future on not only hoping that that
that ripple will win but hoping they win
in such a way that clarifies it
and even then it might be kind of like
uh
you know you're still in trouble sort of
like when a cop tells you to stop
running away even if you're the wrong
even if it's a mistaken identity
you can still get in trouble for not
obeying that so
once they said it was once the sec says
this is a security i think it was
december 22nd
or something like that i was just like
wow i mean
game over for at least for exchanges for
now um
so uh so yeah i think it was smart to
de-list it
yeah i saw i think it was famous that
have uh relisted it
um at the moment i think somebody else
says as well i can't really remember but
i think at the time
it was very interesting because people
were very um
i think there was this idea that you
know when
they first they come for you and then
they'll come for the next one and the
next one and so people are sort of
saying this is an example
of hostility towards cryptocurrencies
it's not about
xrp so do you think that we're gonna
okay we're talking about the states but
let's let's yeah we can talk about
do you think that we're gonna see um
hostility towards it the kind of
possibility that we've seen in nigeria
for example
india turkey um or do you think this was
a genuine
issue with xrp as an isolated case
yeah i think well it's not so much
isolated because there's a lot of other
companies
and groups in the same situation as hot
water but i don't see us going into
a situation like like india or nigeria a
lot of those countries
have been very ham handed and and
not nuanced it's just sort of like oh
we're going to ban all crypto and then
people will complain and say okay we're
not going to ban anything
um the united states has been driven
more by which regulate
we have very old law and a lot of work
that's been done in this
so it's driven mainly by which regulat
which regulatory authority is looking at
something
in this case it's the sec so the sec
really cares just about one thing is is
it a security if it is
was it offered properly and is it being
exchanged properly
according to their rules if it's cftc
they care about other things you know so
the
and then there's money transmission and
ofac and other
regulations that uh different
authorities care about
um and and it kind of which bucket
you're in you know we care very much
about securities obviously being
a securities broker but uh most
exchanges care about money transmitter
license so it depends which which
regulatory authority is after it but i
don't see this
uh as a broad top-down uh government
being anti-bitcoin kind of thing
even if if xrp loses this it doesn't
necessarily have
wide uh reaching impact to other cryptos
because
it's certainly not bitcoin the sec has
specifically said bitcoin is not a
security and they also said that
ethereum
may have been a security at its offering
and you probably shouldn't do that type
of offering again
but it's not now so they've they've
definitely acknowledged that
uh some things are not securities when
they're digital assets so they don't
have the authority over that so it's not
the same as some kind of king or
prime minister or something who has like
all power authority just saying you know
this is banned like we've seen in some
of the
even more authoritarian countries yeah
for me personally i feel like we've
reached that we've kind of gone over
that hurdle
of could this be banned could could
something stop it i mean
especially what's happening in miami um
with the mayor
i'm so impressed i'm so in awe i wish we
had that in london
um i'm absolutely annoyed you know and i
think there are even some states in in
the us which are accepting bitcoin um
for taxes i think it was ohio but then
they they went back on that but whatever
it's
it's movement and it's positive and it's
positive and um so i think we've kind of
passed that hurdle but
you know we were talking earlier and you
sort of mentioned bitcoin as that
sound money and that store of value and
everything else could potentially be
building
um and one of these companies which is
building is vechain
and v chain have um i think i i've read
yesterday have recently
gone live um with cyprus to create the
first
i think it's a covert 19 vaccination
passport basically
using blockchain technology um so you've
been really vocal about everything that
we've seen so far across
the last year um firstly i want to get
your thoughts on covert passports
because this is really hot right now and
i'm actually based in israel where
well i'm based in israel for the minute
where they have coveted
19 passports i've been turned down in
certain places i couldn't get in because
i'm not vaccinated
um you're shaking your head so tell me
your thoughts on this
yeah i think it's just crazy we've seen
this absolutely insane
march of authoritarianism over the last
year it's just really
a human tragedy and uh you know we've
seen this many times in history and now
here we are uh being able to witness it
uh firsthand where you just have
complete and total
uh lack of logic and and in the name of
science of all things it's completely
not science it's totally politics
and you have it wrapped in with all
kinds of other things with you know
social bad social ideas and socialism
and uh you know race and climate and
everything else being bundled into this
this one you know basically cult
which is uh you know an authoritarian
state worshipping cult
and it has its own rituals and and
badges and magic words just like any
other cult
or you know twisted religion in history
uh and it's very murderous and very
deadly to people
and um it's it's completely political
and you have signals like a mask or
a vaccine passport or these things which
are which are really
designed for signaling much more than
any real
uh you know the people who wear a mask
generally like outside
jogging are doing it either because
they're really stupid
and they just don't have critical
thinking skills they don't understand
anything especially actual science or
more likely they're doing it for
signaling which is a kind of a strange
and weird
uh situation that we're in where we have
people so
willing to give their soul to this
religion called the state
that they're willing to just um abuse
their kids
even or let all logic go out the window
i mean you literally have people saying
like
oh i'm so like they're bragging about
getting a vaccine
which is weird enough but then they're
bragging about their kids getting it
and they have kids in in masks with
plexiglass around them
and there's people who are on that side
they're on the side who thinks that
kindergartners
who have i calculated it the other day i
think it was seven
zeros or four or five zeroes with a
seven
after it is what the odds are of a child
even even going to the hospital over it
so it's this extraordinarily it's way
less than a one in a hundred
kind of chance um and it gets less and
less as more people are vaccinated
and uh you know we have more hurt
immunity more people with antibodies
you have people with something with a
far less than one percent chance and
they're using it
and they're and they're putting kids
behind plexiglas and st
taking little children who are
kindergartners and making them wear a
mask
all day long on the playground just
totally not
logical it's not logical it's not
protecting them in any way
at all it's a it's a total sick uh
social signaling thing
and and so you do have a lot of very
strange things going on in the world
right now with this
you know with this whole march of
authoritarianism i think it's quite
scary and dangerous bitcoin is one of
the things that motivates me i feel like
we have so little power against this you
know horrible march of evil
but we do have power over bitcoin you
know it's the one thing that the
authoritarians haven't figured out how
to kill or crush or co-opt yet so we can
just sort of
you get frustrated you can just go throw
throw dollars at the wall and turn them
into sets and at least you're opting out
in some small way
there's a lot there um i obviously i
think you know i agree with you on
everything that you said and i think
that
um something that i saw the other day um
which blew my mind and for me this was
like the epitome
of it was um parents offering their
children
up um for the vaccine for trials and i i
use the word trial because it was a
trial the news reporter said it was a
trial and
these are three-year-olds getting
experimental vaccines and
parents were very excited and they were
signaling virtue signaling and they were
sort of saying
um you know we we we wanted to make sure
our daughter had um
had a say in this oh i'm sorry she's
three
what can i say what kind of state does
she have if you asked her should we be
homeless for a week she'd go yeah that
would be really fun let's do that
of course don't do that um so my
question to you is
is why is it why why is this happening
and
also why is everything being lumped into
one because
if you right now you can tell how
somebody believes about something by
asking them one thing
right like if you if you wear a mask on
your own
chances are you're probably one of those
climate freaks as well
right so how how why is this a thing
like
why are things lumping together what why
is
does that make sense sure yeah
it's the nature of power and
authoritarians you know
we have in the world makers and takers
you have people who build stuff
who do cool things who invent things
they and they make
restaurants and and construction sites
and they invent new computers and
software and they create podcasts and
they create movies and they do stuff
and then you have people who take it you
have people who just take it because
they don't have those skills
so they build up skills that enable them
to take stuff and those skills start out
at the community activist level and
they're the
the brand of uh you know clown in your
local town who's
uh going to all the town board meetings
and making little nitpicky
uh rules to bug people and then they
rise up and become
the next level legislator i don't know
how it works in in uk but
you know in the us would be like a state
senator or a state rep
and then they go up to congress and then
they become under secretary or whatever
it's just
and and all of that is about
accumulating more power so you have more
power over people and you have one group
of people
who think they know better and they
should have the power and they should
have
the resources and they know they should
have the money and that you know nobody
should have nine billion
dollars or whatever that they should
have it bernie sanders should have it
aoc should have it because
they have this belief that they've been
fooled into thinking that these people
know how to allocate resources better
so you have these things where they say
you know oh if we you know we should
nobody should be a billionaire we should
tax all the billionaires it's all kind
of
in line it's all about taking it's all
about taking um
saying oh you know that it's it's based
on greed and jealousy and people who
could never produce anything
bernie sanders nancy pelosi elizabeth
warren
these people couldn't survive in in one
of our startups
for five seconds they couldn't even
probably appear
on your podcast and even speak
coherently other than typical
uh you know nonsensical political
talking points that they do on
every other podcast that they do they
can't have a real conversation
you couldn't have somebody like
elizabeth warren go in and hold their
own in a bitcoin
uh clubhouse room or at a bitcoin meetup
or
or something like that they just don't
have that skill set they have no idea
what they're talking about
they don't know how to build they don't
know how to add any value
to society so all they can do is steal
from the people who do create they can
look at it and say oh well zuckerberg
has more than me
let's figure out how to you know gain
power over zuckerberg
which ultimately translates into having
uh more money so they so they built up a
religion around this and the religion is
one that uh you know has its own like i
say it's it's it's
its own uh magic words and everything
and and
it that's why it ends up being
encompassed because you
you have this this cohesion that
that the members of a group get you know
there's there's human needs that people
have one of them is
being part of a group significance is
another one
um variety is another one you know carl
young's
uh human needs um you know these are
things that this is why people join
gangs it's why people join cults
and this is a cult so people join it and
it's and and the more magic words that
you have around it you know you put your
pronouns in your bio and you say
blm and you wear a mask and you do all
of these other things the more that
people think that that's
you know part of their identity and the
more they believe the
nonsense so people will put people will
actually put
blm in their bio thinking they're doing
something good
like oh i care as if as if those who
don't put it
don't care or as if you don't put your
pronoun in your bio that you're not
supporting trans people or something
it's just a preposterous
sort of notion um but but that's how you
gain power over somebody by
like a frog in the boiling water you
just get them a little bit at a time a
little bit of the time like oh no no
let layla just just just put your
pronouns in your layla just just do that
uh oh no we just need you to say this
and what it is is
is if you let the woke magic you know if
you're dealing with the cults
okay and you and you
ignore them they don't have power over
you so so you know
there's a there's an account that i read
one time about the
uh one of these um voodoo uh like a
witch doctor type of person who put a
curse on somebody
and the curse the person who had the
curse was like ah
like they immediately changed their
whole physiology their state
and they really did become sick so
there's curses where you could put a
curse on somebody and people actually
die
because they believe it so much and if
if
a foreigner goes to one of those
cultures and they say i
put a curse on you layla you're like uh
okay
and you walk out you go to starbucks it
doesn't
it doesn't hurt you brian armstrong just
tweeted about he's
he said he was commending another
company because they
took the tact he looked he took and and
they're
they're saying no politics being
discussed and he said it was courageous
the thing is it's it's it's only
courageous if you do he did make a
mistake
uh in that he engaged and he let the
woke magic into his house in the first
place
as soon as he hired a diversity officer
and he what happened is he tweeted
he tweeted black lives matter because
his employees told them to
and then they you're the frog in the
boiling water they come back oh no no no
brian you we want you to tweet it again
so he tweets it again
oh no no brian you got to do this now
you got to get another diversity
you got to get another one now you got
to do the climate change and if he
didn't stop put a stop to it
right now his entire company would be
run by these people maybe they'd even
throw him out
you know they're never gonna stop
they're not gonna say oh finally thank
goodness brian finally he gave that one
medium post
and now we know that he's on our side he
has pledged
to the church of woke and he is he is
one of us
and we're going to let the high priest
have approved him they're never going to
approve them there's never enough that
you can give
so the only proper response when you
deal with woke lunatics
is to ignore them and not be part of
their religion and not let it have any
effect on
you don't see these people coming to
people up here in new hampshire or
people in texas and saying you know you
better put your pronouns in your bio
because people just laugh at them
and they also there's some confidence
also
where people you know i know that i'm a
good person i know that i
that my beliefs on race are actually way
way way
more productive towards the goals that
you that we we actually want with race
than the the actual you know racists who
are pushing this
blm type of stuff uh and the other non
you know woke nonsense that they do so i
i think that's the reason you know
you you gain power from this
cohesiveness and that's how religion
works you know
the more doctrine you have the more
things whether it's how many times a day
you have to pray or
you gotta shut your lights off at a
certain time all different kind of
religions have these different rituals
and the church of woke is is no
different for sure
yeah i think you know you make a really
good point when you say that
these these people who are
supposedly actually racist or whatever
it is you know anti-fascists and all
this fun that stuff
um they're actually very
counterproductive and they're almost
worse you know
um you know i think as a as a woman i
can speak from like the gender equality
standpoint
and i often say that kamila harris only
got that role
um because she's a woman and because
she's a little bit darker than you and i
that's the only reason i think she got
the role and i think everybody knows
that and
in some ways that is so offensive
like i would be so offended i can't
stress this enough i'd be so offended
if somebody hired me because i'm a woman
it's so
and do you know what i'm so i'm really
true to this i had a
phone call the other day and um somebody
wanted me to get involved in some kind
of marketing and all this stuff and i've
had a conversation
and they're like you know when we need
more women in crypto and i was trying to
i was trying to think to myself okay
well do i tell you how i feel about this
or should we just keep the conversation
going
and in the end i yeah you know in the
end because this is a potential client
um and in the end i was like listen i've
got to be honest
that women in crypto thing it's not a
thing for me it's not this isn't going
to
connect us if you're like pushing this
it's not a thing for me
um because you know if you're saying
that you want me to be part of like your
project and all this stuff because i'm a
woman then i find that offensive
i would much rather you i'd much rather
you want me to be a part of your project
because of the value that i offer
um whatever that value is it depends on
who the audience is it doesn't matter
um but if i'm honest
i'm a little bit frightened like i'm
scared um
because we're going down this path and i
think before covid we were on a path
whereby it's like oh well forget the
pronouns i'm not going to use that
you know if you're off twitter it's
really not happening in the real world
um but but covet is is happening and
it's kind of
and it's like a real world manifestation
of all this woke madness
um and i don't really know what we're
gonna do i don't know whether i'm really
gonna need to take the vaccine if i want
to travel and live a normal life
um i think now it's having real world
implications outside of this pronoun and
blm stuff and
so this is concerning for me yeah
i mean the the the the path to violence
begins with this
religious idea that we're right and
that's that's how wars over religion
have been fought for
you know one one one group prays four
times a day the other praised five times
a day
or you know it's it's this belief or
that belief that people
um you know that people fight over and
they have for you know they have for
years
and so um you know i think it's very
dangerous you know it's not just a
you know woke slogans that you can
ignore it has real world effect you know
these these people are
i mean there's people being arrested
right now um and
you know you see these horrible videos
it used to be shocking but now there's
so many of them we don't even bother
being shocked but you'll see a a mother
being tased in front of her kids
you know because she's at a school board
this just happened the other day she
went to a school board meeting
to complain about the math she didn't
wear a mask so they tased her it's like
what kind of society are we in you know
they
tasing people and stomping on their head
with boots is a bad idea
and uh and and that's you know that's
the side that we're on you know when you
when you say we're right
and we have the law behind us that
that's just a 100
guaranteed recipe for for violence uh
and and we see that and and it's
and and interestingly the um
the problem isn't seen by the people who
are pushing it because
uh they're the they're the cause of the
problem i mean they're the reason that
there's so much violence so they're
looking for any other solution other
than that
um to you know to blame you know they
usually racism or something like that
when it's really just you know kind of
bad policies and
an overall status uh you know pro status
kind of
um you know outlook
so i have a i have a question um
greta thumbbag um what she's been
you know greta yeah greta yeah yeah
greta
okay so okay so look there there's this
push for
a certain kind of um there's a this is
huge environmental push right now um
albeit greta's been silent since covered
she's sort of coming back on the move
um i'm sure she's an innocent very nice
individual
um but behind her there's a machine and
there's of course
there's 100 a machine i can see because
i can tell by the marketing i can tell
by the fact that she's almost an 18 year
old girl
who they continuously present as a 10
year old
um you know so it's kind of like
children and and all this stuff
but do you think that there's actually a
um sinister
um a sinister agenda behind all of this
and before you answer i think in some
cases there is so if i
look at like let's just take the
democratic party as an example
so i genuinely think that they want to
keep the minorities down like i
genuinely think that they want to keep
black people down like i genuinely think
that
joe biden try joe biden says you know
you're not black if you don't vote for
us i mean
how revolting is that and he's done
nothing i
was reading tweets today he's done more
for like the asian community and so on
than he's done for any black people in
america
um all of their promises have fallen
through you know you have you have um
even even in the uk to be honest but
it's more of a thing in america you have
um
you have policies which reward bad
behavior
there's no ins that you know there's
nothing is incentivizing
any good behavior keeping families
together they're incentivizing broken
families
um you know incentivizing riots and
and so on it's so stupid so i do think
that's sinister but overall do you think
there's
actually a genuine sinister kind of push
here yeah i do um a lot of times the
people who are involved are unwitting
and evil come kind of uh evolves
organically
it's like uh it's like a virus
you know you i was a medic when i was in
the navy they call it a corpsman
um and uh so i worked in hospitals and
stuff like that and
um the program was i was in there was a
lot we were in the water a lot and
you know uh and and and so the littlest
tiny
injury on your foot can turn into a
really bad
nasty injury if you're in the salt water
and you don't clean it properly
you know just a little little sliver a
little cut it can
get quite nasty and if you just never
take care of it keep getting worse
i mean you could end up in the hospital
over i mean you could probably die
really you know a bad enough infection
could kill you
and that's the way that a lot of this is
a lot of people aren't really
it's not so much that they have a master
plan for
for evil but they have a plan for
furthering their own power
and that power corrupts and they have a
plan for
uh you know just this kind of
collectivist sort of
you you you are right about i think um
it's it's a very interesting thing with
uh with with race in america where we
have
the group who talks about race the most
i i agree with you is by far the most
racist
and i think their policies have been
terrible and i think that's ironically
why
so check this i just pulled this up this
is this is interesting so
so philando castile democrat mayor
democrat um governor democrat state
george floyd democrat
uh mayor democrat governor alton
sterling democrat mayor democratic
governor freddie gray democrat mayor
democrat governor eric garner
democrat mayor democrat governor dwayne
wright michael brown brianna taylor
every single one of them it's
overwhelmingly democrat
it's a democrat appointed police chief
democrat police unions who appoint the
who
who endorse the democrats democrat
legislatures blue states in many cases
a democrat governor in every single case
democrat mayor in every case
so my question is like is it a problem
of racism
that caused these people to die or is it
something else
if it is racism then we should say well
why is there so much racism in all of
the all of the democrat
communities um if it's not racism we
should ask
you know what it is i think the true
answer uh is more nuanced
you know it's easy to say it's trump's
fault
you know oh they all died because orange
man racist like really well
if it's if you have a democrat mayor
democrat governor democrat appointed
police chief and
a police union that that endorsed the
democrats and all the laws are written
by democrats and they're enforcing the
democrats
and most of the police actually are
democrats too is it really racism they
just came out the attorney general who's
black
uh said that that um in the uh
the uh the george floyd case there's no
evidence that chauvin
was was racist and of course there isn't
because if we wouldn't if there was we
would have known it if
ever in his entire life uh derek chovan
made one racist comment or one racist
joke
or did anything at all racist if he if
he was slightly racist to an
ex-girlfriend in high school we would
have heard about it i believe you would
have heard about it
so the fact is there wasn't any racism
at all
regarding this and most of these other
cases there wasn't racism at all
the problem isn't racism the problem is
statism
statism is the problem you have a bunch
of bone-headed
uh authoritarians eric garner died
because they're of a loose cigarette law
so you have these people who say oh
there ought to be a law
and that's the typical democrat kind of
thing you know bernie sanders wants to
regulate deodorant or whatever
and fuzzy actually i didn't know that
yeah he mentioned that
same same week he said he wanted to
regulate uber but uh
um you you end up with this this
situation where
um you you you know the
the the pro the real problem is statism
you know
uh massachusetts where we used to live
boston has four times the cops
that uh uh san jose has
you know it's just it's and they they
have just they have even more crime and
a lot of these places they have more
cops
bigger budgets why do they have so much
crime um and and it's easy to just blame
it on racism but it's especially
confounding if you blame it on like the
other party who's not even there like
well why
how does how does trump affect
louisville he's not there
you know the the fault of the louisville
violence should
if anybody should go to those elected
officials who are overwhelmingly
democrat
and uh and if it is racism i think there
is some racism um but it's actually on
the left
side uh but more but to be fair i could
do a sound bite just like the left does
and i could say ah
they're the the left's all racist and
they're they're the real racists and
that
that's not quite accurate either i don't
think a lot of them intend to be racist
i think they
they're putting racist policies out
there
and they're unintentionally racist which
is ironic
uh but the bigger problem than race is
just statism if you have a whole bunch
of stupid laws
and a whole bunch of cops you're gonna
have violence and you're gonna have
issues and you're gonna have people
killed of all
of all colors well um what you said
actually
reminds me um of the whole gender pay
gap
issue um and i think it's also far more
nuanced
um you know you can look at the facts
and you can say okay well you know women
are
statistically paid less than men doing
the same job or whatever it is you could
look at the facts and say
more black people are killed by accident
white people whatever it is
but it's far more nuanced um just to go
on a side note i'm one of those people
that i don't believe in the gender pay
gap at all
i'm i'm a huge jordan peterson fan um
and he breaks it down beautifully
um yeah like he he's fantastic about it
um but but i think that you know
with with the with these policies i i do
just i i do
so you see with america america is far
more um
the race relations there are far more
intense than
around the rest of the world okay so
bear with me for a sec
in the uk we don't we don't have this
kind of animosity that you guys have
um even in canada they don't have it and
i'm saying to a lot of canadians
about this and during that time of
george floyd
and then all the blm protests in the uk
we actually started to
um have very similar protests and it was
actually a really sad sight
to see um because we're our communities
are so
integrated um it's just not a thing for
us
um of course racism is always a thing
but but like it to the to the extent
that you have these racial tensions in
the us
we don't really have that um in in the
uk and i do a lot of
bitcoin work on tick tock and uh tick
tock is very heavy
gen z and it's constantly race after
race after race the
issues scrolling through there are so
many issues and and
you know it's just like why do white
people always say this and then a
then a white person comes in and says
why do black people always say and then
and then a canadian comes in and a
canadian's like what's wrong with you
americans
it's just you guys doing this and i can
understand why but but my concern is
americanization is real americanization
is a real thing
and so i worry that it that this kind of
racial tensions will spread globally
yeah we'll export it
well the thing is we didn't used to be
like this either this is a
new thing yes we've had races racism and
racial issues going back hundreds of
years and we we have
uh you know very bad race ra you know
slavery and other things in our history
but this
new thing this this whole uh thing where
everybody is
is um segregated by race that's new
that's like the last five years
has been on a huge huge update because i
remember i was talking to somebody and
they happened to be like a gen z
it was it was a college student and he
said to me i said something and he says
well that's easy for you to say you're a
white male
and i was like totally shocked the first
time i heard that i was like what
what are you talking about what are you
you're judging me by
the skin i couldn't believe it now you
hear that every
five minutes i i actually stopped
identifying myself as
male or white just to get people to
leave me alone
so so and it works great by the way with
the wokes the wokes are all
every single conversation they want to
put me in a box and i just simply say
please don't assume my race and please
don't assume my gender and then they get
really angry especially about the gender
well you're obviously a man i say as i
said
please don't assume my gender i'd rather
not i'd like to be judged by my words
not by being put in the little box that
you can so you can say
oh he's the wrong skin color he's his
opinion is less valuable
no thank you i'd rather have my opinions
be judged not by what somebody else's
perception
is about what my gender is um and
this so this whole thing was kind of
invented uh
you know the first blm protests were
kind of fell flat they were run by
idiots
um it you know and then but that
movement kept trying to come back
and it was mainly that the anti-trump
media
who really ran with this racist racist
racist racist
thing which i don't really buy
necessarily trump certainly had a lot of
problems and he made some stupid
comments
if you talk about stupid comments being
evidence of racism
there's no comparison at all between him
and biden
biden says things has said absolutely
ridiculous things
much much much worse than trump and he's
actually had much worse policies
too so and a lot of the things that
trump supposedly said he didn't he
didn't even say one of the biggest ones
that has been um you know repeated
continually by the media is this lie
that he said that uh
you know neo-nazis are fine people and
he specifically said the opposite of
that he said
i am not talking about the neo-nazis or
white nationalists so if you say that in
a sentence
and in the same sentence you clarify i'm
not talking about the neo-nazis
and white nationalists then you can't
use that as a quote that didn't stop the
new york times
and every other lying media from saying
that and it was even repeated by biden
in the
in the debate so you have this huge
thing in the national con
consciousness of tens of millions of
people which is a lie and there's
hundreds and hundreds of
examples like that that uh that that
pushed this
this race narrative so that contributed
to it and then this idea this leftist
collectivist
you know socialist communist idea that
people should be put into boxes like oh
the
uh you know white people over here and
black people over here and you have this
experience and privilege and all of this
other stuff
and then you end up inevitably with
people saying you know oh white people
say this
black people say that and i i found that
very disturbing
that wasn't a thing and and it's really
sad with gen z because the media
and the leftists has put pushed this
idea into the the gen z's head
that you know everybody with a red hat
or or every republican
or whatever is some kind of almost
character
you know i always want to ask i'm like
where are all these racists
you talk about it all the time where are
these actual
i mean where are the real racists i
don't see very many of them at all like
when we talk about like
all these races racial issues as far as
like real actual races like
actual neo-nazis and actual uh
you know kkk types it's an
extraordinarily tiny tiny
tiny number and so it's like what you
know
it's almost like they're living in 1950
you know that they think that people go
home and
you know mutter the n word about
somebody because they don't like the
skin color
and the same thing you see this with you
see this with with to a lesser degree
women and
and um gays and other other things where
you have this kind of gen z attitude
like
oh yeah it's going to be real hard for
her to get a job in software because
she's a woman it's like
where is that a thing actually show me a
ceo who's a tech ceo
who's legit sitting there saying oh i
got to fill this engineering job
we really need another c plus plus
decoder but
the only ones who applied one of them is
kind of brown and the other one's a
woman i mean
that's just not a thing that person
would be such an
outlier they'd be such a weirdo they
wouldn't even be
a normal i mean do they exist yeah sure
you can dig it up i mean the media will
find these people
even even for the media it's hard you
gotta really dig to find somebody who
actually will look you in the eye and
say no
women don't know math as well as men i
mean that's just
it's a character you don't need to spend
any more effort on that character than
you do on somebody who thinks any other
ridiculous thing they're not a
mainstream part of society but the media
has tried to push it and make it seem
like you know half the country
is racist sexist uh homophobic
anti-asian now is is another new thing
uh
and and you and they you know they have
this this this horrible murder
and they immediately try and make it
into a race issue i think it's just a
murder issue the guy
who who killed the original group of
people who who mostly
were asian it seemed that he was just a
crazy horrible
evil person who but and even if it was
motivated by race it's like oh
okay but does that mean it's it's a
trend you know it's it's just it's very
easy for the
media to manipulate these things in a
way that increases division
and people start thinking each other
it's it's very sad i think people think
more in terms of color in the last five
years than ever before
you see somebody and then and then they
start to think because they've been told
and because the left has pushed and
pushed and pushed say
black people are this way and then this
white people are this way
then when you when you do hire that
engineer you have some people who think
oh we hired a black engineer and that's
a tragic tragic thing that is just
evil and i blame the left for that i
don't want to see somebody as a black
engineer
i don't even want to care about it and
we shouldn't care
and this division and this idea
categorizing people
by race is a bad way to categorize and i
use that line a lot i tweet
it every single time i see something
stupid and it's oftentimes big
corporations citizens bank did it the
other day they have a thing
black uh banker bank customers do this
who cares i don't care what whether what
color skin somebody has how much balance
they have in there you know
but black people like the drive-in
window more like
why why do you need to do it and i
respond every time with that and the
reason i use that line is because it's
hard to attack
i just simply say categorizing people by
the color of their skin is a bad way to
categorize people and i think that's a
jordan peterson line actually
um and it's because i learned if you get
into a dialogue
you get into an argument i don't want to
get into an argument i'm just
saying a statement that's hard for them
to disagree with um
and uh so anyway i i think that it's
tragic that the media
and the left have and the right to but
especially the left in the media has
really pushed this
this narrative to put people in in boxes
and divide people
and i feel horrible and and the biggest
victim of it is
uh the people that are supposedly trying
to that they're trying to benefit from
this
the biggest uh drawback i i see people
now
where i get resumes where the first
thing they mention on their resume is
that
their race i get resumes and they'll say
i'm uh
filling the you know i'm i'm this race
and i i'm an engineer you know kind of
like you you women you know i'm a woman
in bitcoin
if your first thing that you're putting
on your resume is your race
and then the second and third thing is
some race related club that you're in a
race related
thing i feel bad for you and you've been
sold a bill of goods by the left who
isn't there to help you
they're there to get your votes and they
view it as as the black vote
for example um which they think is their
birthright just like when the
when the democrats were um you know in
in
in league with the plantations and the
and the kkk you know they were some of
the biggest races historically
in history and there were there was no
like party switch but
um yeah i think it's just absolutely
tragic what the media has been doing
yeah i i obviously totally agree with it
all
um and i think that i used to work um
as a traditional journalist in london um
and
my time there was fascinating and i knew
i didn't belong
um i knew it i i didn't know what the
problem was until i left but but i felt
like something wasn't right
what wasn't right was the way that i saw
the world um and you know i think i made
a comment about the metoo campaign i was
working on a sunday
um so it was really chilled you know
we're all just only a few of us in the
office in the newsroom
and um i made a comment about the metoo
campaign
and i was absolutely slaughtered for it
it was so unprofessional i was just
people just came after me in the
newsroom and uh
the news editor did nothing and i'm like
what is happening
um and you know you can't say anything
you can't you can't commune communicate
anything
and um you know i think you're totally
right when you say that
if the most interesting especially on
twitter the most interesting thing about
you
in your bio is that you're there's the
color of your skin your sexuality and
your gender you must be a pretty boring
person
um you know like i feel i have so much
to say
and if the most interesting thing about
me is talking about being female like
i'm pretty damn boring then because
you know there's not really much it's
already much exciting to say about that
so
it's a real it's a real tell if somebody
puts that at the top of their resume you
know it's a real tell
um so okay we've been on for nearly an
hour so i i don't want to keep you too
long
um but how do like moving forward with
all of this i
spoke about this with michael arrington
and he says that
we're going down a dark path and
eventually there'll be a flipping and it
will change
a good friend of mine said that he sees
the next 30 years
as a dark as a dark
time what are your thoughts do you think
that you know where
there'll be a correction at some point
i hope so um i do see us going into very
dark territory and we we've done this
many times in history where you do have
these long
periods of darkness because once you
have authority like they have with the
with all the lockdowns and the masks and
stuff like that it's much harder for the
people to get that back
it's much easier for them to uh
just increase once you have this big
huge um
authoritarian apparatus of tyranny and
it's and once you have that in the power
of the
authoritarians which we have now it's
ten times harder to get it back and so
it's much easier for them
to just add some new thing like to say
you know okay now it's now it's the next
vaccine you know i mean
they're already talking about these yeah
every six months
yeah yeah oh we we just know that this
one in a hundred year
uh virus is it's here forever now so
you're going to need another
vaccine passport in six months and then
and then you're going to have you know
biosurveillance and then it's like well
shouldn't we also use that to stop the
child molesters too and save the
children
and if we're gonna stop the child
molesters shouldn't we also stop the
human traffickers and also what about
the drug dealers
yeah you know maybe we should just stop
the drug users too
you know and before you know it you get
this thing where it's like oh okay
you're a drug user
or you're you you didn't i mean there
there's people who were who were saying
that
you know i mean basically treat people
who wear red hat as a terrorist you know
the
this whole uh you know it's a it's a
it's a very
bad combination when you have huge
authoritarianism with uh
zealots and lunatics and so so i do
worry about it i'm optimistic about
technology i'm optimistic about human
nature
i'm optimistic about uh people's ability
to
to um you know fight back uh
and and new ways to fight back like
technology you can opt out through
bitcoin
or something like that but it is scary
overall i mean i try and be optimist i i
really hope that
uh there's a backlash the good news is
there's a lot of people i mean you look
at florida people just opt out they're
just like man
not being a member of the church church
awoke uh
thank you and and there's got to be
something internal where people say wait
a minute i'm on the side
that's tasering moms and locking
kindergartners in a plexiglas shield
with a mask on their face
all day long while they're on the
playground for for something that has a
one in
ten thousand chance of killing them what
have we done here what are we thinking
you know uh sorry there's a spider on my
mic i just jumped sorry
i don't know i i was distracted earlier
because my dog was chewing my core
he moved okay i'm
yeah but that i mean that's what i think
i i feel like it is a very dark time but
i'm
i'm cautiously optimistic we do have
some checks and balances in place and
other things i i would like to see
you know it's very hard to fight this
kind of stuff because
the best people to fight it are the ones
who don't want to
the people who are trying to build you
know who just want to mind their own
business naval has mentioned before that
he doesn't want anything to do with
politics it's divisive zero-sum game
but the problem is if we all sit by the
lunatics are going to take over the
asylum
these people are absolutely evil and it
and we can't just say oh
it's republicans versus democrats or
it's this versus that
it's evil versus good and we can't sit
on the sidelines as much as
i would like to i would like to just
never even mention it i wouldn't
even like to talk about it there's not a
lot of gain even just coming on and
talking about it there's not
there's more harm than gain and you can
end up in the in the sights of the woke
or the antiphon and they could try and
make things miserable for you for a
little while but
um you sort of have to because if you
don't those people
who spend a life figuring out how to get
power over others
are in a very good position now to just
continue to
increase that power and and and uh i
tweeted the other day
my friend told me a story about his
family from iraq
and they had worked really hard to they
made money ages ago
and then they the the patriarchs of the
family were like hey
we have enough money now we can afford
with trusts and stuff to send everybody
to school everybody's going to be an
academic so they're all
academics and poets and thinkers and
scientists and just
wonderful and i said that sounds awesome
and he said yeah we taught
we we they were taught growing up you
don't need to be in the military service
and political
service is a little bit beneath you you
can be an academic or philosopher
our family has enough resources that
we're going to put a priority on
schooling and i said that sounds awesome
and he said no that's not the end of the
story he said saddam came along and they
couldn't do anything about it
he just took over and those who fought
him were killed so you can't just stay
above the fray and you can't just ignore
politics
politics won't ignore you politics these
people will kill you
over a loose cigarette just like they
killed eric garner
and it was the statists who killed eric
garner not racist not donald trump
it's status statism is the most evil uh
religion and uh the the the status
out there will will they won't kill you
but they will order somebody to kill you
over anything no uh offense is too
trivial
wearing a mask loose cigarettes uh
you know one of the other ones on my
list there was killed um
over a warrant the original warrant was
was basically over a joint
it was i think it was a misdemeanor or
something so
you know the the state of the aoc bernie
sanders elizabeth warren crowd will
murder you
dead for not pledging to the church of
woke so you got to just
opt out get away from the church of woke
and uh and and you know focus on peace
and stuff but
but we do have to fight it i mean i
think that it's worth fighting
some of these authoritarian things you
know i'm i'm personally
becoming more and more against masks we
have a the you know
the mandate is ended in our state uh but
i'm more getting along the
the the tucker carlson line which is you
know i'm thinking about
saying hey i'm offended if you're
wearing a mask your mask is making me
uncomfortable please take it off
uh because we just have to stop the
insanity otherwise they're just
you know they're they'll put shots in
the arms of kids and
uh having them wear armbands and every
other crazy thing so
but i am optimistic about people ability
to do that people are kind of fed up and
and
hope and that and the ideas of the woke
crowd are so so so bad
the lockdowners and the wokes they're
all the same as you mentioned you know
the climate
blm lockdowners woke uh pronouns they're
all the same
arrangements of idiots and and
you know as i mentioned one important
point is you know that
as i said woke magic only works on
yourself and you talked about when
you're in a newsroom
yeah the the the professions that are
i've already pledged to the
church of woke they have it the hardest
so you can't be
a journalist an entertainer uh look at
gina carano
she gets cancelled from one of the most
popular shows because she didn't want to
put pronouns in her bio you know
um but that's just because same as brian
armstrong she was in the space to begin
with
you won't see somebody else you won't
see kid rock getting canceled like that
even though he's an entertainer
because he never participated her
biggest mistake was to engage them in
the first place you should just
discounted them as
lunatics that they are and maybe she'd
still have her job
but certain professions media obviously
politics
uh academia and the and uh you know you
know
you know the the press and a couple
others you just can't say anything
academics just can't say anything i feel
really bad for people
in academia but there's a lot of people
on the other side who know that this is
crazy and they're
they're fighting against it or they're
just opting out and just not allowing
somebody to say because the lunacy gets
crazy
and crazier and what happens is as more
people opt out they have less power
i mean you can't go to like a republican
um
and i don't mean to always make it about
republican democrat but i'm just saying
uh it's harder to attack your typical
like ted cruz with some woke thing
because he's already opted out he's like
no
it's not a thing so who do they attack
they attack academics talk to an
academic
talk to somebody in the media or talk to
an entertainer and all three of those
people
i guarantee you will tell you that
they're pressured i know an academic
who was outright pressured uh just to
basically pledge
to the church they actually went to this
this is an adult professor
the university went to this adult
professor and said you need to read this
book
there's a book about critical race
theory because somebody in their class
said some preposterous thing that you
know like they didn't
whatever they didn't they didn't say
them right magic words
um but as more people opt out eventually
you know they're going to eat their own
and you'll have your own you know you
know ellen was
was roasted because she did something
earlier you know you have your own
members of the cherokee church of woke
who are getting tried for heresy it's
like oh okay you you did these these
these and these
statements but you didn't say this other
statement or you didn't pledge to this
group or you didn't donate enough or you
didn't give enough of your soul
so you're going to have even academics
but they're all wimps because they need
the jobs really badly and so you don't
see the academics
you know fight it but eventually you
will because the
the woke lunacy won't have anybody to
feed on but itself
and then they'll starve and then
hopefully die down
we hope yeah we do hope and i think that
um you make a really important point and
it's something that i've really actively
tried
um to do is as i've grown my own
audience
um people know where i stand so nobody
can hold me
to any bs standard of any kind right so
like since the beginning of lockdown
i've said i'm not okay with that
since the masks i've said i'm not okay
with it for the very reason that you've
said because you know it's a gradual
you know it's it's masks today but what
else is it tomorrow it's forced
medical experiments on children tomorrow
right um
so yeah absolutely you know i i don't
ever want to be
held to account by my audience for
um you know not being woke enough like
if you're woke leave
you know leave i i yeah you got to be
uncancelable
you know you have to treat it just like
a crazy religion
you know if somebody came in and said oh
you know layla the moon god
uh requires you to turn your light
switch on and off four times a day and
you need to you really ought to be
posting
that you're doing this and say hey i did
the life switch thing
or you know whatever and you just say uh
no
and you move on that's the only response
for these folks
because they're violent i mean if you
get into it with them they might kill
you you know so you're better off just
just ignore them i mean just last point
on that i
um i work with quite a few really
amazing different companies in the space
and um somebody i have a really good
relationship with one of the ceos and um
he told me that somebody reached out to
him and was just like how do you have
leia
representing your your company um have
you seen her tweets
you know i was just like i only work
with good people i only work with
non-cancelable types so good luck you
know
um so they thought that was really funny
and the ceo himself is super red-filled
so he was like yeah it's chill it's not
it's not a problem um but it's been so
good talking to you bruce um i've been
really excited to talk to you
i've seen your tweets and to be honest i
i was surprised um
when i when i saw um certain things that
you tweeted and i was like oh wow we're
really on the same page
um i was really surprised it was really
refreshing and so thank you so much yeah
it's refreshing to talk to you too it's
great to uh
i mean it's probably important so i'm
glad i did this because
we should all be talking about this and
hopefully you know some people maybe on
the fence or
or maybe even a little bit on the woke
side will just look at this and wake up
because there's a lot of really really
good people i have a lot of i
you know i didn't really come from the
left but i certainly you know i lived in
massachusetts i have a lot of
very left uh issues like and i've been
talking about anti-war
and police violence and the drug war for
20 years
um and uh so
i definitely have a lot of camaraderie
with a lot of people on the left
who've been you know just driven to this
insanity they got to step back and look
at it so i think it's important what
you're doing
so keep up the good work keep being
uncancelable
uh i think that's one of the most
important things in today's world
because then you can actually
speak truth and that probably makes you
one of the top journalists in the world
right now you know how rare it is like
when you said journalists like
barely you know a dozen actual
journalists it's certainly not any of
the people at any of the
the media um you know propaganda
mouthpieces you know new york times is
just a media
mouthpiece for a very narrow specific
thing
and they're even in the case of like
they're they're within
wokes talking to other wolks they're
they're like they're starting to attack
each other
you have a whole bunch of infighting
with the reporters there it's really
hilarious
you know it's and it's an ever dwindling
uh sphere of influence and readers
because
it it's just a bunch of you know ultra
ultra blues arguing with each other
about
you know who who who put the pronouns in
their bio first
and uh nobody cares and then and then
the rest of their so-called news
which isn't even journalism by any
stretch it's just it's just mouthpiece
talking points for state media
so you you're in a great position to be
uh actual truth-teller
who and you can only be a truth teller
if you're uncancelable so that's good
good for you
yeah i hope so you know that is that is
the goal um
i just kind of want freedom normality um
and yeah we don't have freedom we don't
we don't have anything
and um it kind of comes down to when you
don't allow people to take personal
responsibility
it's just socialism you don't allow
people to take personal responsibility
they just won't no one will do anything
like i've even seen here in israel they
have um a scheme where
what was similar to what we had in the
uk furlough where they paid people to do
nothing
um for a year and uh it's an issue here
people are getting paid they're still
getting paid and people aren't really
going back to work
um and then it brings all of us down to
the lowest common denominator
um and it robs them of a year of
experience they could have gotten doing
something else
yeah absolutely um
yeah i just i i just hope things do get
better
and we can live a more free life um i'm
trying to come to florida because i just
love that it's open
so that's the goal but um thank you so
much it's been such a pleasure and um
hopefully
we can catch up and have a more positive
discussion um at some point
by all means sounds good it was great to
uh great to talk to you
all right bye guys and thank you so much
for tuning in we will see you all
next week
[Applause]